washington is on edge this morning after
another frightening incident near
capitol hill a man parked his truck in
front of the library of congress
claiming that he had a powerful
explosive and then he was demanding to
speak with president biden
buildings were evacuated and the roads
were closed for several hours before the
standoff ended jeff begaze is on capitol
hill with more on the story jeff good
morning not the most effective way to
get the president saying you have an
explosive
well you're you're right gail and it
really was a tense situation in part
because this guy was live streaming
during this bomb scare his
anti-government rant now this morning
investigators are still actively trying
to figure out why he did what he did
and whether anyone else was involved
had information and evidence of what was
in the bed of his truck
and there were some things that were
concerning 49-year-old floyd ray
roseberry of grover north carolina drove
his pickup truck onto the sidewalk in
front of the library of congress while
broadcasting live on facebook he claimed
to have explosives you can shoot me and
kill me right here and blow up two and a
half city blocks he requested to speak
to president biden what's up you job
and suggested if police fired shots at
him it would trigger explosives in his
truck
when you shoot these windows out the
revolution is on even harder
snipers posted around the perimeter and
bomb sniffing dogs search for additional
explosives while police spend hours
negotiating
first started doing that with a white
board
just writing messages back and forth
we used a robot to get a telephone down
to him
but he would not use the telephone
around 2 p.m thursday roseberry
surrendered a relief to police
the tactical units that were close by
took him into custody without incident
police did not find a bomb but did find
possible bomb making material
the incident comes more than seven
months after the january sixth attack on
the capitol a recent bulletin from the
department of homeland security warned
of the current heightened threat
environment posed by individuals and
groups engaged in grievance-based
violence
and so right now the working theory is
that he was acting alone but as i said
investigators continue to look into this
case
his ex-wife she spoke to us and she
believes that he is mentally unstable
but she says she never expected him to
do something like this
tony unstable indeed jeff thank you very
much